leider was geht ab hier soll max merz
willkommen zu diesem video wir spielen
heute gta 5 und ich glaube es wird heute
richtig lustig weil ich habe mir mods
installiert für gta und gta mit mods ist
sowieso immer lustig findest du das auch
hören konnte mir leid das war ein
bisschen unnötig aber motzing gta und
ich gehören einfach zusammen
ich zeige euch das mal wieder obst äpfel
zurück das jetzt erstmal so dieser
grundsätzliche trainer beim kann man sie
alles möglich installiert zum beispiel
bodyguards nehmen wir mal michael wir
beschützen uns jetzt stellt euch mal vor
dann können wir uns zum beispiel zu
diesem bodyguards ein cooles auto nehmen
wir mal militär zum beispiel den
polizeiwagen und jetzt gehen zitiert
jetzt feierten ihr einfach für mich ist
doch so cool ich muss noch okay ich hab
noch ein zweiter sagt vorbereitet wir
machen jetzt mal ein bisschen rampage
ich und meine bodyguards damit direkt
abonniert
ich glaube weil die ein bisschen kassel
waffen haben leute hab nicht so krasse
waffen zerschlägt mit rad ein bisschen
falls ich nicht so richtig kommentieren
kann halo das polizei ihr seid meine
bodyguards los macht sie fertig macht
sie fertig genau dies sollte aufpassen
für schützling war kurz meinen kollegen
ich mache mir kurz unbesiegt jetzt wenig
musik war freunde und ich komme immer
wieder ins sg nied jetzt könnte mir gar
nichts ich rechne ich mal kurz diesem
hier zeigen das ist so lustig hat einen
daran und ein daran hat jetzt das
spektakulär aussieht meinte nehmen wir
zum beispiel den polizeihubschrauber und
da nehmen wir das polizeiauto und dann
per hubschrauber am polzei auto gibt es
nicht dürfen dann gehen wir zum beispiel
an das polizeiauto das auto und dieses
auto findet ja schon
ran und das versteht leute wie cool ist
das kann ich es obendrauf kann ich
darauf wird er mit dem tisch oder sterbe
ich sterbe nicht mehr im winter
eigentlich als ob das gerade passiert
kommt jetzt rein
die fahrerin rausgeworfen also ich
befinde mich sozusagen gerade auf einem
abstürzenden luftschiff bin unbesiegbar
und können mir vielleicht wie wärs
probleme probieren uns auf das
luftschiff drauf irgendwas coolsten ich
glaube die fallen gerade irgendwo vor
mir herunter
ja leute unbesiegbarkeit hat ihre
vorzüge geht das bitte komm papa kommt
hinterher glaube das funktioniert und
dann können wir dieses riesige flugzeug
rein aber irgendwie sind wir nicht
schnell genug kommen wir noch dran kommt
ich lade kommen wir kommen näher
leute ich glaube es hat keinen sinn aber
mal schauen ob wir vielleicht irgendwas
perfekt okay leute seht ihr der trainer
hat immer die möglichkeit einen zusammen
jetzt sind hier oben drauf und als ob
und jetzt können wir ganz einfach weil
wir vollidioten sind goethe wir
wegfahren
er kann sogar wegfahren ich wollte
zeigen werden kommen dann hätte dann
platzt mir aber gelangt hier freunde es
ist so cool es ist einfach nur cool
leute halte ich habe richtig lust
spiderman zu machen und mich so
irgendwie durch die hit zu bewegen indem
ich einfach so mache die ganze zeit
alter wie cool ist das
es ist wie können einfach spiderman
seien leute was sage ich wir können
spiderman sein wer ist eigentlich bei
einer mine im vergleich zu uns leute wir
fliegen zu einem leute wir fliegen zu
einem alten freund das große flugzeug
großflugzeug und hin und hin
ich muss das machen sonst komme ich
wahrscheinlich dass im flugzeug sie die
schneller
ich glaube diesmal klappt ist er kann
uns nicht entkommen diesmal
und leute
ok
zackig sind wenn er die leute raus
fliegen ich habe einfach viel zu viel
spaß dabei es tut mir leid ich hoffe ihr
habt auch spaß beim zuschauen und ich
kann ja eigentlich einfach crashen so
kann eigentlich einfach ohne probleme
dieses flugzeug in die bertram weil ich
ja musikverbände weil ich es wieder
ausgemacht
vielleicht war das leben als mensch
einfach nicht für uns bestimmt
vielleicht war ein anderes schicksal
ein
verwaltet euch niemals an land in einen
delfin aber in eine kapsel was
unglaublich süßes bemerkt mich junge
menschen
nein das ist mir zu kleine katze weg
eine katze sein und wir sind wir
ich glaube ich weiß nicht genau was das
für ein vogel ist aber wir sind dieser
vogel oben auf dem kran und ich bin ja
greift jetzt bin ich vogel auf dem
krankhafter besteht ja sturzflug
sturzflug sturzflug ich bin jetzt wieder
unbesiegbar
wenn man schießt ein scheiß der lustig
okay leute glaube wir wissen alle was
das bedeutet wir werden jetzt menschen
auf den kopf scheißen für alles was sie
uns vögeln ist auch vögel angetan haben
und unter kopf getroffen ich weiß nicht
ob mir die damit knapp
seht ihr euch ab getroffen ich habe
getroffen ich habe getroffen und wieder
getroffen
ja was mache ich hier eigentlich aber
nicht nur das können wir tun
liebe freunde wir können auch auf zb
building drauf und mal wieder
wisst ihr was der provoziert mich aber
auch es ist einfach nervig also eher
wild halt jedes mal wieder
es hat geklappt leute wir sind zweiter
rein
wir sind spiderman wie kein anderer
mensch auf diesem planeten ist jemand
besonders weil eigentlich seht ihr wie
sagt man so schön ist es nicht für den
boss wollte gerade sagen
nein tue das nicht
das nicht ich bin auch er unbesiegbar
ok mit unbesiegbarkeit ist es vielleicht
ein bisschen anspruchslos aber
vielleicht können wir noch irgendwie ein
paar coole stunts oder sowas machen was
könnte man hier oben drauf lustiges lied
ist jetzt nicht da wo ich jetzt daran
dass ein bisschen blöd oder spielen ich
werde da jetzt noch ein einziges mal
oben drauf gehen und dann werde ich als
irgend etwas cooles oder irgendwas
lustiges von hier oben runter machen wir
machen es einfach das naheliegendste und
werden mit einem richtig coolen fahrzeug
herunterspringen wir müssen uns ja auch
noch für eventuelle andere folgen
irgendwas aufbewahren was cool ist und
warum spricht man hier unter am besten
mit magath haben rs nehmen wir mal
anlauf und probieren vielleicht
irgendwas cooles sind wir ob er wird von
hier oben runter in front unten helm auf
das wichtig wenn man musik bei infront
unten backflip hinkriegt okay wir
probieren es aus
und das war der front lab das war der
weg lab und kann man das land
explodierte explodiert es ist nicht
explodiert unglaublich die fahrzeuge
sind immer noch zerstörbar also eine
sache noch die polizisten her mich grad
böse abgefuckt in dem die mich geärgert
haben dass er werden wir dass wir einen
guten alten piraten tagen machen und
werden sie gepflegt kielholen diesen zu
schwer
wir sehen so schwer aber ich bin weg mir
zumindest ein bisschen
das war der game fresh und damit haben
wir das ende der heutigen folge erreicht
es war unsinnig wie noch nie zuvor auf
einem kanal aber auch extrem lustig ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen und dann
sehen wir uns beim nicht mal wieder
macht's gut